اه سيد زوكربيرج، أنت والشركات
التي سبقتنا، أعلم أنك لا تقصد أن يكون الأمر
كذلك ولكن يديك ملطختان بالدماء، لديك
منتج، لديك
منتج يقتل
الناس عندما كان لدينا سجائر تقتل
الناس، ربما فعلنا شيئًا حيال ذلك
لا يكفي أنك ستتحدث عن
الأسلحة، لدينا ATF لا شيء هنا،
لا يوجد شيء يمكن لأي شخص أن يفعله حيال
ذلك، لا يمكن مقاضاتك
الآن، لقد عثر السيناتور بلومنثال وبلاكبيرن،
اللذان كانا مثل الثنائي الديناميكي هنا، على رسائل
بريد إلكتروني من  شركتك
حيث حذروك بشأن هذه الأشياء
وقررت عدم توظيف 45 شخصًا
يمكنهم القيام بعمل أفضل في مراقبة
هذا الأمر، لذا فإن خلاصة القول هي أنه لا يمكن
مقاضاتك كما ينبغي،
وستكون رسائل البريد الإلكتروني هذه رائعة للحصول على
تعويضات عقابية ولكن
أغلقت قاعات المحكمة كل أمريكي أسيء معاملته من قبل جميع
الشركات التي أمامي، ومن بين
جميع الأشخاص في أمريكا، يمكننا
توفير حماية شاملة من المسؤولية
لهذه ستكون المجموعة الأخيرة التي
سأختارها، لقد حان الوقت الآن لإلغاء المادة
230 التي تتكون منها هذه اللجنة  من
الناحية الأيديولوجية، معظم الأشخاص المختلفين الذين
يمكن أن تجدهم، لقد اجتمعنا معًا من خلال
قيادتك، سيدي الرئيس، لتمرير خمسة
مشاريع قوانين للتعامل مع مشكلة
استغلال الأطفال